I don't ever want to give up my peace of
mind just to give somebody else a piece
of my mind oh that's so good TK yeah
don't hand me your misery and expect me
to turn it into joy for you
[Music]
one more talk aboutable for you TK
this is the root of your unhappiness
unhappiness is when your expectations of
how life is meant to be going go unmet
and this explains why a kid in Africa
who gets rice I was born in Africa I was
born in Botswana kid in Africa who gets
rise can be euphoric but a billionaire
in a Michelin star restaurant in West
London his three Michelin star State
comes without the sprinkle of dust or
whatever she got on it he will be
visibly pissed off and complained
because his expectations of the world
and how life should be going going there
so one of the ways that you can make
sure you're happy it's not loud
beginners it's just like having better
expectations reasonable realistic ones
and this applies for relationships if
you have healthier expectations of your
partner you will have a better
relationship if you have unreasonable
expectations of their perfection when
you are fluid yourself you should expect
to have a really miserable relationship
they will never meet the expectation
expectation is The Curse Of Happiness
if you want to be happy
don't just have reasonable expectations
though limit your expectations
eliminate the unnecessary expectations
don't lower your standards but eliminate
any expectation that isn't serving you
and is getting in the way of your
happiness that's right and an
expectation is different from a standard
an expectation is an assumption I have
about what you would or should do and
that that tends to get us in a whole lot
of trouble a standard on the other hand
is a value that I have and I choose to
enter into agreements with other people
in a way that respects and honors those
values right so we don't have a mere
expectation that everyone's going to be
at the studio at a certain time we have
an agreement about that based on a
common value that we share but without
that agreement it would just be an
assumption and and you see this a lot
not just in terms of like what we eat or
or a material possession options but
where it really kills us is in our
relationships we have so many
expectations based on what a person
would do or should do if they really
loved us if you really loved me
you would do this if you really loved me
you would have said it that way or you
would you would have never forgot that
and we talked about trauma earlier it's
like
there are a billion and one reasons for
why a person can really love you and
wouldn't do the very thing that you
would expect them to do what if they
have an addiction
what if they have weaknesses you don't
know about what if they've been
traumatized you know like you don't know
all the different what if they have a
physical disability what if they have a
mental disorder we don't know all the
different things that affect what people
do and so if you can let go of those
expectations and say all I'm gonna deal
with
is agreements whatever expectations I
have I'm gonna make them known and see
if I can work together with that other
person to transform that into an
agreement and if we can get an agreement
out of it we have a peaceful Arrangement
on the other hand if it's just an
expectation I'm not going to let that
get me into trouble that's that's a
recipe for misery that's the Insidious
side of our expectations too quite often
our expectations go unstated and then we
make ourself miserable or we make the
people around us miserable because you
didn't meet the expectation that I never
stated in the first place imagine if I
had an expectation Mallory gets here
every day at like 8 A.M but imagine if
my secret expectation that she should be
here at 6 30 a.m joke's on you I was
here at 6 30.
because I secretly expected that you
would want that of me
thanks for finally meeting my
expectations Mallory you're welcome but
that's that's the thing like and no one
would get anything from that now she's
she got here really early she thought
she got here early but she merely met my
expectations how is anyone going to meet
your expectation unless you form an
agreement with them but in order to form
that agreement with them you have to
State what the expectation is and by
stating that expectation quite often you
realize how absurd the expectation is
that why do I even have this expectation
of someone else oh it's because of the
story I'm telling myself about what they
should do for me
what is going to benefit me the most not
us not you not our relationship not our
community but how can you benefit me
well what else does that a parasite does
that and so a parasite has an
expectation I'm going to take and take
and take and never give I'm gonna make
you sick with all of my taking I don't
have to give anything that's what
expectations do parasites don't have
standards they merely have expectations
I'm going to extract whatever I can from
the host I'm gonna get what I can until
I can't get anymore Professor Sean
what's this gentleman's name and the
clip
oh Danny do you remember oh I know this
one it's Stephen Bartlett okay Stephen
Bartlett so I love what he was talking
about earlier like the person at the
Michelin star restaurant with an
expectation can be absolutely miserable
I saw this last night during the sigur
Ros concert now I surprised my wife with
second row seats and uh they were
expensive I couldn't afford the first
row seats actually and so they were
several hundred dollars for these second
row seats and um there was a woman who
was in front of us sort of caddy Corner
within 10 feet of me and she was sitting
there
just scowling and yawning and she seemed
so frustrated that she was in the front
row but she clearly wasn't Center Front
Row she was slightly Askew and so it
wasn't as perfect as her expectation was
but Bex went into it with no expectation
she knew we were going to a concert and
then she found out cigaros oh my gosh
this is so amazing I didn't have this
expectation and then we get there and
they uh start walking us to the seat and
it's like oh wow we're we're down in the
the lower section wow how great is this
oh wait we're not even there wait we're
in the pit
and then we go to the second row we're
seated there in the second row she had
no expectation for all of this and all
of a sudden where we were Amplified her
happiness but if she had the expectation
the woman in the row right in front of
us had oh something slightly off now
she's discontented because even though
she's in the perfect concert with the
perfect seats it's not perfect enough
for her expectation and by the way
while I don't know this person and I
can't comment on this particular
instance for a lot of people that is the
mo that gets you into the front row
it's the ability to get unhappy real
fast in a way that makes other people
uncomfortable for a lot of people that
is their primary form of power my
ability to get angry my ability to be
difficult to deal with
make you uncomfortable make you squirm
you know so that guy you know who's
upset about the steak and the powder not
being on there maybe he was miserable
but maybe he was also flexing and so for
a lot of people misery becomes a
powerful negotiation tool and I guess
hey if that's your joy that's your joy
but like we talked about earlier man
I don't I don't ever want to give up my
peace of mind just to give somebody else
a piece of my mind oh that's so good TK
yeah don't hand me your misery and
expect me to turn it into joy for you
yeah yes I hope you enjoyed that
highlight from the minimalist private
podcast if you did and you'd like to
dive deep into full episodes of the
private podcast head on over to patreon
just click the link down in the
description the private podcast keeps
our YouTube Channel 100
advertisement free because
advertisements suck but if you're not
ready for that just yet head on over to
this video on our YouTube channel
[Music]
thank you